Robert Downey jr. is first starring
vehicle since ending his tenure as Tony
Stark aka Iron Man in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe didn't quite set the
box office on fire in fact Doolittle a
new take on that classic children's
character who talks to animals is
shaping up to be one of the biggest
bombs of 2020 and this only January its
opening four-day total came in at just
under 60 million dollars worldwide and
well that's respectable for a January
release Dolittle had to do much much
better to have a solid chance of
breaking even the movie was budgeted at
an eye-watering 175 million dollars and
for reasons we'll get into momentarily
it likely ended up sporting a much
heftier price tag than that on paper the
film looks like a winner Downey in the
lead and all-star cast including the
likes of rami malek of Tavia Spencer and
Tom Holland voicing all of those
adorable animals and an oscar-winning
writer director and Stephen Gaghan so
why did do that all flop so
spectacularly at the box office
the first signs of trouble came with
Duda toll after its initial test
screenings was found to be in need of
heavy shoots by Universal in order to
better connect with family and overseas
audiences the studio decided that the
flick was in dire need of more talking
animals more slapstick comedy and if the
critics are to be believed a whole heck
of a lot more fart jokes something felt
wrong that's coming from a guy who loves
this man but for undisclosed reasons
Gagan did not return for these reshoots
instead of the studio dubbed Chris McKay
and Jonathan Liebesman
to shoot the new footage which also
certainly pushed the movies final budget
well north of 200 million dollars but
not only did the reshoot push the flicks
budget into the stratosphere they the
latest release by nine months and
foreshadowed a troubling fact Universal
wasn't quite sure who it was making this
movie for now don't get us wrong Gagan
is a fine writer and director but the
fact that he was hired for Doolittle
only serves to illustrate that this was
a film conceived with no clear audience
of mine his previous credits didn't even
approach the realm of family-friendly
his stocking trade as serious dramas
like havoc traffic and Syriana it was
gag ins cut of the film that went over
like a lead balloon of those test
screenings and universals have Sam to
course-correct by bringing in McKay in
the biz
to ramp up the silliness was obviously
the wrong move the film was all over the
place in terms of tone described as a
grand adventure for the adults and far
some poop jokes for the kids ultimately
it failed to win over either audience to
make matters worse the film debuted in
January a traditional dumping ground for
flex the studios know nobody is going to
want to see this coupled with its
troubled production history cause
critics to view it with suspicion before
they even set foot in the theater and
once they did those suspicions were
confirmed poor critical notices aren't
toys the determining factor for tentpole
films but in regards to do the toll it's
hard to make the case of the film's
reviews didn't punch some cannon ball
sized holes in its hull critics weren't
just unkind
they were absolutely brutal as summed up
by the words of NPR's Scott Tobias do
the tool is not a film do litoral is a
crime scene in need a forensic analysis
something happened here something
terrible something inexplicable this one
had been stabbed multiple times and only
a thorough behind-the-scenes examination
could sort out whose fingerprints are on
what hilt to put things into perspective
consider that as of the making of this
video do little stands at 18 percent on
Rotten Tomatoes the universally reviled
Cod switch to swiftly becoming
synonymous with unbelievably
ill-conceived fiasco sits at 20% if do
little it opens a no competition
whatsoever the damage might have at
least been mitigated but compelling the
flicks myriad problems it's had the
distinct misfortune of opening against a
franchise movie that had no trouble
generating word-of-mouth of a much more
positive nature now it's time to be good
men who in the hell want to sing that
song good man good man what you gonna do
nobody ever accused the Will Smith
Martin Lawrence buddy-cop pictures bad
boy and bad boys too of being high arts
and its have been nearly 17 years since
the former flicks release but bad boys
for life which has been in development
for years and which was made without the
involvement of franchise director
Michael Bay arrived - surprisingly solid
reviews and built a strong pre-release
buzz which resulted in over performing
wildly the modestly budgeted flick is
already reeled in over 100 million
dollars which is the second best showing
in history for Martin Luther King Day
weekend this surprise smash all but
sealed the box office for
of doolittle which will now have to puts
up on a reasonably strong overseas
performance to even come within shouting
distance of breaking even it's a
stunning reversal of fortune for downey
who went from starring in the
highest-grossing film of all time
last year's avengers endgame to a film
that will be remembered as a towering
flop if is remembered at all check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos buy your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and to the bail
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]